[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 19th of
January I'm Kate Andrews the spectator's
economics editor and your host this week
coming up on the show
the government says it will block
Nicholas surgeon's attempts to bring in
new laws to make it easier for people to
change gender and mcwherter and Julie
Bendel will be on to discuss the Union's
new dividing line
the southeast has done very well out of
this round's allocation of the leveling
up funding but not all MPS are impressed
I'll speak to Katie balls for our
political update
the rich and Powerful gather at Davos
this week does the conference do any
good Martin Vander Ware will join me
Goldman Sachs has fired more than 3 000
people yet saw their value increase by
billions Sam Leith joins me to talk
about the so-called Surplus Elite
and finally Noma often called the
world's best restaurant has announced
its closing is this the end of fine
dining as we know it I'll speak to
Olivia Potts and Murray Sutherland
before we get going thank you to
canacord community wealth management for
sponsoring this episode of the week in
60 minutes can accord or experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who offer unwavering support in
challenging times visit candywealth.com
for more information and if you enjoy
spectator TV then do subscribe to our
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
first up Nicholas surgeon wants to make
it easier for people to obtain gender
recognition certificates but Rishi sunax
government is blocking the proposed
legislation in the first ever use of
this kind of veto power to explain the
route I'm joined by journalist Anne
mcwherter who writes this week's cover
piece and the activist Julie Bendel
Ann and Julie thanks for joining me and
you write in this week's magazine about
the Union's new dividing line gender
talk us through it okay well um you know
this is a very complex legal issue an
existential issue actually for for many
uh women about the definition of sex the
definition of legal sex and whether or
not
biological sex takes precedence in
equalities legislation over gender
gender identity assume and assume gender
identity now
the Scottish government has promoted
what's called self ID it's past uh
legislation which allows people to
change their legal sex uh effectively by
them by declaration without going
through any medical procedure without
medical advice and only by living in
their assumed uh new legal sex for uh
three months now
this is being controversial in Scotland
it was you know it went through a very
acrimonious debate in the Scottish Palm
but it was passed it was passed by the
Scottish Parliament and it's been
overridden uh under what's called
article 35 by the UK government all the
grounds but this new interpretation of
legal sex does not conform to
westminster's understanding of uh
equalities legislation and that it would
cause problems now it's it's quite
complicated to get into this but just
think of this someone popped up to
Scotland for three months changes her
sex and comes back down again
um they will have a gender recognition
certificate identifying them if they
were previously women now as a man but
that gender recognition scenario will
not will not be valid in England because
England requires you to have a medical
diagnosis of chat or gender dysphoria
and live in your new sex your new gender
for a minimum of two years but you'll be
coming down with these uh and
transcripts are already organizing this
uh kind of transmigration for people to
come up to Scotland to get there uh use
your gender recognition certificates but
these will not be recognized South of
the Border except of course they will be
recognized because there's no way of
identifying an invalid Scottish gender
recognition certificate they're not
going to inspect people's grc's at the
border so these people people will be in
you know asking to join uh Single Sex
women's groups with these GR sees behind
that there's a more complex issue about
whether or not biological sex takes
precedence over
um over gender in Scotland the legal
because of it was a resolved in a
landmark case in the quarter session
last month the category of woman has
been changed to include men so legal sex
is now place predominance over
biological sex you cannot exclude
someone with a gender recognition
certificate on the ground but they're
biologically male or they have male
bodies they are women for all purposes
as the law says that's not how it's
interpreted South of the Border it's
certainly not the way that sir
Brotherman exceeds it and many women's
groups here are beginning to realize how
significant that is are saying that this
seriously damages the right of women to
exclude biological males from Single Sex
groups like you know support groups for
on domestic violence or rape Julie is a
feminist activist what do you make of
all this
well first of all if you include men in
the category of women I mean it renders
our sex-based rights completely
meaningless that there's absolutely no
protection no Assumption of Single Sex
space which we fought for and gained
only because the sizable minority of men
will
commit acts of sexual violence and
domestic abuse and the like towards
women so no one ever said all men are
rapists we said enough men are will
commit these acts towards women that we
actually need some protection from that
and if we do then experience male
violence we need some Refuge from that
so that's the first point the second
point is of course that we have a law
that makes it very clear that rape is
committed by a person with a penis that
is the Bedrock of the offense of rape
and all of a sudden and this is where
legislation bleeds into the cultural
norms and what we accept as a society
um all of a sudden we have some
newspaper uh reporting on male rapists
who identify as women with the phrase
her penis
and we have also um a requirement
in some courts and certainly this will
be in Scotland and again uh using some
judicial discretion it's also across
England and Wales where women who have
reported men who have sexually assaulted
and raped them are required to refer to
that person by using female pronouns so
referring to the rapist as she her or
she'll be admonished by the court now
this is an obscenity in the cultural
sense when we get to the legal sense of
course it's an absolute disaster because
it means that men who identify as women
who every single piece of research shows
commit sets of violence against women to
the same degree as do other men
um will be able to get uh uh well that
they have a get out of jail
free card we see men in women's prisons
that terrify women where prison officers
have said openly that they dare not uh
call these men who are posing as women
in prisons to task because they might be
deemed to be transphobic and even the
prison service has been captured we know
that the MOJ has been captured and
pretty much every institution by this
transgender ideology so to say that men
can be in a category of women what's the
point what is the point of even talking
about sexism if we can't recognize sex
Julie let me ask you is your primary
concern about the changes that the Gen
this gender legislation bill would bring
in about the loosening
um of the rules and restrictions around
getting a gender recognition certificate
or is it the gender recognition
certificate altogether by that I mean
are are you particularly concerned about
the changes which would see somebody
essentially able to get one of these
certificates quite easily now whereas
before you had to go through a long
process with medical supervision or is
it the concept of the certificate
altogether that really worries you
it's the concept of the certificate
altogether but I think that this has
made it far worse to suggest that
children
um Can in fact just decide that they are
the opposite sex and wish to live
as the opposite sex and everything that
comes with that which is the peddling of
puberty blockers and then cross-sex
hormones which of course are
irreversible but I'll tell you what what
I do think in terms of of trans rights
well first of all so-called trans women
in other words biological men do have
rights they have men's rights and of
course trans people who live as the
opposite sex and I do know some and
count some as my friends
do need to be able to live dignified
lives by which I mean if they're passing
through an airport with a male passport
but presenting as female I do not wish
those people to be discriminated against
or treated
um without dignity so we do need some
provision to protect those people living
as the opposite sex because that is how
they are living and that is a reality
but I think the idea that you can change
your legal sex and then all of a sudden
become recognized as women to all
intents and purposes is a danger to
women this isn't about keeping trans
women out of women's prisons Hospital
Wards or refuges it's about keeping men
out
um and one of the legal problems as I
understand it is that there has always
been ambiguity around these certificates
so you're not just operating
um from a place where perhaps what
Scotland is trying to pass is in
conflict with the equalities legislation
as Westminster understands it but that
there's confusion in general about the
legal status of these certificates which
as an additional layer of difficulty
when trying to sort out this issue
yeah I mean there is a conflict between
the 2004 gender recognition act under
which people are allowed to change their
legal sex change their birth certificate
get gender recognition certificates and
the 2010 equality action this has never
really been addressed never really been
resolved what takes precedence is it
biological sex or is it gender identity
now what's happened in Scotland as a
byproduct of this introduction itself
ideas not only that it's accelerated rap
massively the speed with which people
can change their legal sex is also
redefined legal sex as as as taking
precedence over biological sex than it
is for all purposes you are a woman now
in Scotland so everyone wants to have a
a woman to be dealt with by a woman
doctor she risks a prosecution for
discrimination if she uh rejects uh a
male bodied trans woman who has a gender
recognition Edition certificate because
they are women in Scotland now as I said
this is not the interpretation in the UK
the suel Abraham and the Home Secretary
has made very clear that she regards uh
biological sexist taking presence over
uh gender identity and the reason she
says that is because there is this
provision in the 2010 equality act which
says that trans women can be excluded
from all women groups like you know rape
support groups they can be excluded
where there is a when it's a
proportionate means to achieve a
legitimate aim whatever that means in
other words written into the 2010 act
there is this Primacy of biological sex
because how can you how can you exclude
a trans woman from a single sex group
without reference to their birth sex
okay
I mean there's all sorts of problems
with that because of course it's also a
criminal offense to expose somebody's
birth sex if they're transparent with a
gender recognition certificate none of
these issues have really been addressed
this has exploded that what the Scottish
government's move here has exploded this
whole issue it have to be resolved I
think it's a very good thing actually
but it will go to judicial review and
ultimately to the Supreme Court because
somebody has to reconcile these
contradictions
but in the in the short term I mean it's
you know this is overlaid Remember by
the Constitutional issue and one of the
reasons the SNP has promoted this is
because well it's a kind of provocation
is to show that the UK Tory government
are nasty bigoted tourism transphobic
where Scotland was really nice and
Progressive and you know all the rest of
it also that the Tories are overriding
the Scottish Parliament running Russia a
full frontal assault on Scottish
democracy is how Nicholas sturgeon has
described this it's not section 35 is
part of the Scotland act it's part of
the parcel of devolution it was
supported voted for by the SMP in 1998
and it's precisely there to address this
kind of to reconcile these
contradictions across the border and the
fact that what's happening is the
Scottish law is running coaching horses
to uh uh UK equalities legislation and
it's trying to in reduce self ID in
England by the back door because the
presumption of the of the LG GT groups
The Stonewall in particular who've been
promoting this over the last decade is
if they get it established in Scotland
you know the rest of the UK will go
along with it because it's too difficult
otherwise you can have people changing
sex at the borders so they'll have to
just accept grc's South of the Border
and that will will move us very far down
this road
Julie do you think the equalities act as
it exists now is broadly right or do you
see the side of the SNP in their
argument that the process could be made
slightly easier slightly more relaxing
just slightly more inclusive for
somebody who's trying to transition
I don't want it to be easy at all in any
way or possible for a man to say that he
is a woman and to have that legal
recognition and legal right no I believe
people should be allowed to live as they
wish to express their gender if they
think that that's what they have
innately as they wish I do not want them
to take our rights there is a huge clash
between the rights of men who identify
as women and actual women I think that
Nicholas sturgeon is a disgrace to women
she is about as feminist
um as
David Cameron she is an absolute
disgrace
as a politician and I just wish that she
would stop her posturing and get off her
perch and recognize that what she's done
is harmful to women and that her Legacy
will be that she put vulnerable women in
more danger than they are already in hmm
Nicholas surgeon insists Julie that
she's protecting women and protecting
the trans Community do you think that
ultimately this argument comes down to
questions about gender though or
questions about independence and how do
you feel about these questions about
gender and sex getting wrapped up in
questions about whether Westminster or
hollyrood gets to make these decisions
I agree with what Ian says she's
she's ridden the coaching horses through
legislation through the equality act and
she clearly either does not know or does
not care that what she has done with
pushing this legislation through and
ignoring those women's groups that work
with Abused women
is that she has given rights to men over
women and that she has given rights to
rapists and to sexual offenders
and this is not to say trans people are
sexual offenders because they're trans
it's to recognize that they are natal
males and that they sexually offend at
the same rate as do other men
Ian where does it go from here it was
just mere days ago that Rishi sunak was
up in Scotland talking about cooperation
and and trying to work together and now
he has a real fight on his hands you say
it's going to the courts but how does
the politics play out as well
well there's been a there's been a lag a
huge lag here because I mean it's only
really now that it's become people in
Scotland are becoming engaged with this
issue I mean up until now everyone
broadly assumed you know that it's it
was about transgender rights it's just
about protecting my minorities from
discrimination but it's not it's about
very much more than that I mean they are
already protected trans people already
have protection from discrimination this
is not about trans rights in fact it's
really about women's rights uh as Julie
is uh as has said and it's only very
recent I mean there have been people who
have been arguing about this for a long
time like JK ruling for example who has
been you know absolutely demonized about
uh has been treated appallingly by not
just by
um uh trans activists you know but by
liberals in general in Scotland who have
really you know they've uh regarded or
they're accused of basically being
transferred
um and that's because I think because
people didn't didn't weren't really
grasping what this issue was at that now
it's only now that this has been uh have
there's been this explosive debate in
Parliament and people realize what
self-id means they realize that actually
police Scotland has for a long time now
have been recording uh offenders even
sex offenders under there assumed their
gender identity not their biological sex
so you do actually now have women
rapists in Scottish jails
um and you have offenders can change
their sex now
um after they're prosecuted so they can
be moved into
um into women's you know a male natal
male sex offender can be moved into
women's jail just by announcing that
they're female and and actually and
we've also discovered that some of them
are changing back to the original uh
gender or sex when they leave that
prison I mean it's it is it creates all
sorts of problems and as I think I
explained that you know it's it's
undermined it's created huge anomalies
in the UK and the introduction the
application of equalities legislation
because in Scotland now it's absolutely
clear
um gender identity expresses over
biology biology biological sex doesn't
really have any legal status it's only
your legal sex that matters if you have
gender recognition certificate you are a
woman trans women are women now in
Scotland just as Stonewall has been
campaigning for for many years South of
the Border that is not the case in the
interpretation as I say is very very
different and women do appear to have
protections which allow them to exclude
people who are biologically male from
certain groups
um and I think what's happened in a way
is that this this politics of this has
you know raised this this fundamental
issue but it's also created a very
interesting unionist
Coalition of or very articulate women
North and South of the Border who are
are just not prepared to go along with
with all this and I think the most
significant move there has been the way
that uh cure storm or the labor leader
UK labor view is suddenly made a u-turn
this week before
um uh the this law was vetoed and said
well he's not he's concerned about it
too but then I suppose real problems in
the labor party because of course the
Scottish labor leader Anna sarwar
which labor nsps didn't allow conscience
vote on this whipped labor MPS into
voting for this SNP legislation so you
know real political uh divisions on both
sides it split the Scottish national
party very fundamentally I mean this is
not by no means are uh our most SNP
members on side of what's going on
they're bewildered by it because you
know what really does this have to do
with Independence but if you look at it
from the from um you know uh kind of the
Strategic point
political point it creates a new a new
border division which the SNP can say
well you know here's here's England
writing Rush shot over the interest to
discuss the Democratic role of the
Scottish Department all this kind of
stuff well no doubt this is a very
delicate topic and the contradictions
that we've discussed here will be coming
to the Forefront and we'll be discussing
them in the weeks to come and stay tuned
for that in the meantime Anna Julie
thanks for joining me
the government has allocated more of its
two point billion pound fund for
leveling up but not everyone is pleased
please wear that money is going and with
circuitama at the world economic forums
conference in Davos Switzerland this
week is the labor leader managing to
convince Business Leaders that he is a
prime minister in waiting to talk about
this week in politics I'm joined Now by
our political editor Katie Bowles
Katie there's lots going on in
Westminster this week not just the
showdown between Rishi nak and Nicholas
sturgeon over the gender recognition
bill but also over leveling up and
there's a lot of frustration even in the
Tory party over where this new
allocation of funding from the 2 billion
pound pot for leveling up money is gone
talk us through it yeah so this is the
second of free adaptations of the
leveling up pot and lots of bids went in
I think over 500 bids at just over 100
have received so I think it's fair to
say there are more unhappy MPS than
happy MPS you look at that those figures
um and this was you know not just for
Tory MPS it's for labor MPS too but I
think there are lots of MPS complaining
that they you know feel they're the
letter forgotten path I didn't think
it's helped that we've had you know run
to the third prime minister so some of
the conversations perhaps they've had
with one prime minister where they felt
like so that you know the area or their
bid was particularly heard hasn't
necessarily carried over and then
there's also a question about where the
funds are going so if you crunch the
data I mean there's a few different
readings of it but it's certainly the
case that um you know some constituents
in the South have got quite a lot of
funding and therefore red wall MPS are
saying well wait I thought leveling up
as pitch in 2019 was all about you know
helping the middens and the north now
there are clearly deprived areas and
areas that needing help across the
country but I think uh given the current
polling and also the fact that lots of
these red wall MPS think that Russia
student has less appeal in the area than
Boris Johnson did I think it's just
adding to this anxiety from those who've
missed out that you know there was one
really they've been left hand you know
to hang out to dry here and and so
therefore
interestingly since Rochester city has
gone in so much efforts gone to keeping
MPS together on side but this feels like
a point where um it is not uh working
the way number 10 would have hoped Katie
is it fair to make assumptions
um about how the Tories might be
thinking about the next election from
these funding allocations for example
would it be fair to say perhaps Rishi
sunak isn't as focus on those votes in
the red wall and perhaps more focused on
those seats where you could see more
competition between say the Tories and
the live Dems I think it's probably too
early to say that in the sense that I
think it's definitely the case that you
speak to senior figures in government
they think some of those live damn Tory
seats uh you know ones that are actually
quite competitive uh where they where
they stand a chance and you can link
that up there are so many things that go
into consideration then when you're
appointing these you know pots of money
they don't think it's just and also the
fact labor Gap you know I don't think it
as much as uh you know we might think
it's just someone looking at the
Electoral math and thinking this works
this doesn't and I I think it's actually
a process of looking at the areas that
need it the problem is it feeds into the
anxiety of MPS who are already worried
about their seats who do have their
perception that um you know some MPS
saying in some of these you know red
wool marginal seats a lot of them have
not got it and I think they're really
banking on it and as you know what was
going to help them keep their seat given
uh you know brexit Boris Johnson Jeremy
corbyn the three factors that helped the
tourists in 2019 are no longer in play
right
and there's one more round of funding to
go though to be allocated do you think
it's likely perhaps that uh those seats
will get a bit more attention in that
final round especially as we get closer
to an election which again big question
mark over that date but it will be
closer than we are now certainly the
message that history you're trying to
send today and fairly saying you know
don't just wait give up all hope and
effectively I think saying don't throw
your toys at the pram there is enough
around to go
um but there is I think there is a great
hearing and again this is more
complicated than just you know thinking
oh there's a rich constituency there's a
poor constituency but I think the fact
of Richard Cena has got funding Jeffrey
Cox's has got funding and lots of people
have pointed to factor Alicia currency
has got funding
um around the mountain and saying is is
that really where it should go and of
course if you look at the projects I
think there's an argument in all these
cases but it is just um I think adding
to the sense of what is leveling up
meant to be doing and it's a problem the
Tories have had ever since leveling up
really was a slogan which is it's hard
to Define it actually defines the party
and right now lots of MPS who thought it
would help them in the next election are
worrying that it was going to fail to
live up to that well indeed it's very
hard to make it on a promise when your
MPS will Define it in a different way
and that's never really been established
on to a different topic Katie and on to
your politics column this week you write
about how rashishi Knack and Kia stama
are each trying to tell a different
story about themselves in the context of
the stavos conference talk us through it
yes I think in recent years Davos I
think it's safe to say has gone out of
fashion in terms of a place that you
would want to be seen at least as a
conservative politician so Theresa May
of course went
um David Cameron George Osborne Boris
Johnson did not go and actually banned
all his ministers and Richie sunick is
following that tradition he is allowing
a representation in the form of Kami
Baden up I think it's fair to say that
the international trades actually is not
particularly enthusiastic about the
summer either quite Keen to stress that
she is a not peering on any panel right
meanwhile on the other side labor
kierstama and Rachel Reeves are
attending they are sitting on panels on
different discussions and I think they
want to have this moment to show you
know we're on the world stage I think it
works for both sides in the sense that
I think the two the two perceived
weaknesses so for stalma it's that labor
is anti-business and the two areas of
originally leads over Starman that's on
the economy and also on you know working
with foreign leaders now obviously going
to Davos should help him with both of
those measures and then for everybody
Scenic I think one of his big weaknesses
is he just perceived as being out of
touch the fact that he is viewed by many
even in his own party as a member of the
global Elite due to his personal wealth
his wife's wealth uh the fact he had
possession of a green card and when that
came out lots of touring pieces you know
it's suggesting who's a citizen of
nowhere so I think the last place where
she's unac wants to be seen right now is
Davos in Alps
um and instead wants to show he's
focusing on priorities here and as you
say kiosama is trying to look Prime
ministerial he's trying to suggest to
the world that labor is going to be on
the side of business do you think he's
convincing people I think Rachel Reeves
um is getting lots of good feedback uh
you know I quite a Tory pier in the
piece he went to uh breakfast where she
was speaking and the shadow Chancellor
and saying you know he really wanted to
dislike her but actually found her
annoyingly convincing or reassure not
reassuring is probably a word too far
um and and that was worrying them
um I think there's an interesting
question though in terms of at the
moment labor are doing almost like a
Blair Playbook and they're trying to
mimic the Tories and various issues so
um NHS reform they're talking about
they're talking quite tough on
immigration they've gone to Davos these
are all things parts of the left of the
party will hate yes John McDonald went
to Davos but when he went to Davos he
had quite a specific message right which
is almost your time is times are
changing you know you ought to change
interested which is not the message of
Kirsten Rachel Reeves they are saying if
labor gets in Britain is open for
business Etc
um and I think this far away from an
election if we work on that idea it's
probably 18 months away and the position
slavery are taking are ones that are not
popular with the left of the party the
fact that I think labor look like they
are heading to a big majority means
they're staying on side but it's quite a
long time to keep up you know taking
these positions which ultimately are
unpopular for some of your MPS and I
think it's a question of if the polls
were to slide at all and I mean at this
point
you can just imagine that labor MPS
could despite the fact this was still
suggest a large majority if the labor
leads somehow the next year went from 20
points to 12 points I think lots of
Labor MPS would suddenly start to
question some of the direction of the of
of the leadership in terms of taking
these positions so I think that's
probably
um one to watch
Katie thanks for joining me
speaking of Davos is anything really
achieved there The Spectators business
editor Martin vanderwear writes in this
week's column that he's pretty cynical
about the conference I'm joined by
Martin now
Martin thanks for joining me on
spectator TV so you're not joining from
Switzerland nor am I as you write in
your column this week our invitations
got lost in the mail I know it's funny
that it happens every year yeah shocking
and you write to them you update your
address and you're still not indicted
yeah you're kind of waving at them
saying hi remember me but no no no the
the the great stiff card with the
freebie invitation to the outs it just
just never arrives and then you know
I've been waiting waiting waiting and
then then I get these you know other
commitments get into my diary so say
this year I didn't make it up in the
column I really am tomorrow going to
driffield in East Yorkshire
ladies luncheon Club who will talk much
more sense than most of the people I
think that's a very good point
um for our Watchers at home who aren't
as familiar with the world economic
forum's annual conference can you just
tell us a little bit about what Davos is
and what we're making fun of yes so
Davos is shorthand for this uh normally
annual conference in the ski resort
luxury ski resort of Davos it was
started I think in the early 70s by a
German Economist called Klaus Schwab who
was a professor at Geneva University it
evolved in the 80s into something with
the grand title of world economic forum
and through very clever marketing and I
must say hats off to Mr Schwab who's
still running this thing
he managed to attract
a combination of world leaders
heads of pretty big businesses from
around the world Limelight Seekers
virtue signalers of all kinds they're
attaching themselves to it so it's
become a jamboree of I think maybe
there's around 700 people this year
um and its agenda and its content gets
some coverage in the world media so
people kind of think this must be
important but actually it's a it's a
huge Talking Shop it there's something a
bit
vulgar I don't know what you think I
think something a bit vulgar about all
these mostly immensely rich people and
self-important or actually important but
certainly Rich privileged living in
their silos of talking to other Rich
privileged important people flying in in
private jets discussing the problems of
the world including the problems of
poverty and inequality from a position
of extreme elitism so so in that sense I
am rather glad I've never actually had
the invitation I think the conference
has become known as as this meeting
point for the world's Elite whether they
be the political Elite the financially
even the media lead to some extent and
the public over the past few years have
increasingly seen through this I think
there have been a lot of accusations of
hypocrisy because certainly pre-covered
the main talking point of Davos became
climate change and yet everybody was
flying in on their private jets and they
still are I mean that that kind of
behavior hasn't changed but this year
the narrative around the conference
almost seemed crafted before it started
which was with the cost of living crunch
happening worldwide how are you going to
justify this extremely lavish conference
where you know champagne is simply on
tap and you can tell there's been a bit
of a PR spin reportedly a lot of the big
parties have been scaled back but I mean
what's all to me is is people are saying
you know you're going to have to abandon
your free market capitalism and your
push for globalization at this
conference and really focus on
inequality as if Davos has ever really
been about free market capitalism or
globalization in the truest sense I mean
you have the the richest people in the
world as you say Martin the politicians
and the businesses coming together to
put together crony capitalism not free
market capitalism and there was uh quite
an amusing
uh blog yesterday of somebody who's
there puts together comments and quotes
from people who are there saying if you
really want to understand it it's it's
like a golf tournament where you have
kind of photocopier vendors and you have
businesses and the the salesmen are
trying to sell the photocopies and
that's basically what it is though the
the the there's no competition no one
else gets to sell the photocopy it would
be very clear the potential customers
are very often get government so I'm
told my mole out there tells me the
Indian government and Indian state
governments are hugely sort of over
represented there and there are plenty
of you know Western businesses trying to
sell them stuff Siemens the German
company I saw had signed a deal selling
a thousand trains to India that kind of
see it's really a sort of sales
conference disguised as a very high
level talking you don't have to pay a
lot of money to get in yeah
so what's on the agenda this year um the
I believe that the the formal theme is
cooperation in a fragmented world what
do we take away from that well they
first of all I think they had they
started with a sort of economic report
where uh a large number of economists
said we're heading into a recession wow
that's that's a real Revelation right we
didn't know that
um and then I think what it is it's
about how do you steer your your nation
or your giant Corporation through the
combination of inflation recession the
Ukraine conflict populist unrest in
unexpected places around the world
weather events all this stuff a
concatenation of adverse factors
um my source says it it so far it's all
dooman and Gloom I don't know whether
it's going to light up uh they've got
some celebrities there Idris Elba was
lecturing them about something the
rapper will I am I'm not familiar with
his work but he's there he's there he's
there Tony Blair's there apparently the
funniest guy so a lot of celebrities
yeah they're a lot of crypto
um players there cryptos rather out of
fashion everywhere else but a whole lot
of them have gone to Davos to sell
whatever they're selling being out of
fashion I guess I guess my last question
to you Martin is to what extent is a an
event like Davao still revelant post
covert I mean um obviously Russia is is
a big topic of discussion there and and
Russia's not welcome at the office this
year as I understand it
um but you know thinking about the
relationship to China with China to
Europe and the US in particular and
those trade Wars that are starting up
again you know if the theme was
cooperation there isn't a lot of
appetite for cooperation at the moment
in fact a lot of these geopolitical
dividing lines are being drawn as we
speak
um does that make a conference like
Davos even more difficult really to sell
especially to the people who need to
spend a lot of money to get there
well let's try and take the most
positive view sure we can which is to
say of course it's good
that top people powerful people talk to
each other and it's good that they can
meet in circumstances where sort of some
barriers are removed so probably the
conversations in the in their very very
expensive champagne bars and so on are
more valuable than the frankly if you
look at it online slightly vacuous panel
discussions about you know what's going
on in the world economy which it seemed
to me to be
um revealing nothing new at all but it
is useful that that people who run giant
corporations do meet people who run uh
governments and so on and have some
meeting in mind say let's not dismiss it
all together what's irrelevant about
Davos is the sense that Davos man the
archetype the the guy in the private jet
who thinks his own opinion is
tremendously important and the world
should listen to it and so on he's
really out of fashion now I think
perhaps Tony Blair has archetypal Davos
man and you know the world doesn't
particularly want to hear from him
anymore so I think good thing that there
are a lot of conversations in the
sidelines and probably some friendships
being made some useful contacts if
contracts and deals are being done and
that's ultimately good for the citizens
of the the you know buying country as it
were fine good luck to them but don't
don't
um don't tell us that we have to listen
to you because you're wiser than the
rest of the world because you are on the
Davos invitationalist that's my general
view Martin thanks for joining me thank
you
Goldman Sachs recently fired more than 3
000 employees but saw its stock rise by
billions the spectator's literary editor
Sam Leith writes this week that he finds
the whole story quite pleasing but is
this really good news Sam joins me now
Sam great to see you on spectator TV so
you wrote for coffee house this week
about Goldman Sachs decision to fire
roughly 3 000 employees and how this is
expected to have increased the company's
value by several billion pounds and you
found the whole thing quite amusing
yeah I mean I'm afraid my reaction to
this was not that of a kind of deeply
informed macro Economist
um but somebody certainly found it very
funny that the figure which the bottom
line of the market cap of Goldman Sachs
went up 3.3 billion was almost exactly a
multiple of the 3200 people they laid
off which say that each employee
um by not being there made the company
worth more than a million dollars more
um and this trap is very funny on the
grounds that generally
you know we would assume that an
employee is there because they're held
to add some value to the company rather
than subtracting it
well you write about how this is a wider
trend of Bing companies at the moment
Facebook laid off 11 000 workers and saw
its stock price jump uh Elon Musk got
rid of roughly 75 of Twitter's Workforce
without it making much difference uh to
how the website runs what do you think
this says about how these businesses
were operating before these firings
well there's this this um
a good phrase which I I borrowed from
the report I read of surplus Elites I
mean I've never been sure about Elite
um as a as a noun for a single person
but that seems to be the way people are
using it now
um but I think it kind of
implies all hints that you know the
sector of the the workforce that we've
tend to think of as a kind of prokaryote
to the people whose jobs are at risk
from industrialization and mechanization
has tended to be kind of manual labor
you know there's things that can very
obviously and easily be done by robots
and this seems to me to Herald a sort of
shift
um into position where management itself
is something that can be done with fewer
people it can be automated more and that
suddenly the precarious are exactly
those people who used to be going out
the p45s to their manual laboring
colleagues
um I mean it the problem of course is as
well is that you
management and all those sorts of White
Collar jobs are much harder to quantify
you know if you're
you're punching rivets or assembling
things you know you can do a sort of
taylorization assessment of how
much work you're doing per hour how much
work the machine does whereas as we all
know people in you know well-heeled
management jobs seems to spend an awful
lot of time kind of drinking coffee and
holding meetings in which nothing is
really discussed so you know one thing's
where where's it all going to end I read
today
um that Microsoft
um I I I wouldn't claim to know for sure
that their influenced by reading my
coffee house blog
um but are laying off 10 000 workers
worldwide so it it's certainly a trend
and I think people are discovering you
know if you lay off 10 000 people
maybe the bottom line goes up by however
many billion um and we we might see a
bumpy ride as they start to experiment
with how far that can be taken I'm
speculating here Sam but I do have to
wonder if all of these redundancies
would have happened pre-covered
um and I'm just thinking about that mass
Exodus from the office and people moving
to working from home and you know there
was a lot of discussion at the time
about how
um for a lot of people that was easier
and they probably would have been in a
lot of these jobs people who say already
own their property who own a large piece
of property who have that extra bedroom
that they can work out of and we were
talking about all the benefits that came
from having a desk job certainly a high
income desk job that can now be done
from home but you know a big question
mark was always going to be what
businesses discovered during this time
um and when you know going for that
coffee break and exchanging pleasantries
in the hall and that kind of day-to-day
interaction was no longer accounted for
in the job what were they going to
discover when they were just looking at
the Hard numbers about what you were
producing and and some people thought
that was going to lead to some
redundancies as companies realize they
can make efficiency gains and they
didn't actually need as many workers as
they had hired
well maybe I mean you'd think that they
make certain efficiency savings even
without cutting stuff by simply not
having to rent all that very expensive
office space and I think we've seen it
an awful lot of that in terms of the way
big companies have rearranged um
and there are questions about how much
you can tell whether people are on the
skive
um I know there's been a lot of
needle in a number of companies about
the way in which
you know managers are using sort of
tracking devices on your computer to
check how often you're actually in front
of your desk it's a little big brother
for me but yes apparently it is
happening but I think there's
you know we're seeing a lot of that a
lot of that post covered stuff probably
shaking out but in general it's maybe
it's just a wider thing about the fact
that a lot of people in management don't
do all that much day to day and can be
can be replaced with more people I mean
the problem the sort of wider problem
and here's where you okay I think will
have much more sensible things to say
about it than me is that obviously the
economy
um to work doesn't just need people
producing it needs people consuming and
robots and machines and chat gbt are
very very good at the first first half
of that but they're not so good at the
second
um
I mean I think somebody I think it was
one of the comments on my piece said
that Henry Ford had boasted that he
could soon make 80 of the workforce
redundant and he said yes but who's then
going to buy your automobiles
um
I mean you may have an answer to this
but but what is what is the solution
what's what's the producing is all done
by a very small number of modestly paid
people
who's going to buy the things that are
consumed well this has been a concern
for I mean throughout many generations
you know what are today's technological
advancements going to do to the
workforce are they going to destroy the
supply and demand economy and all the
rest of it and the truth is that those
threats just have not come to fruition
yet
um you know people have been made
redundant by automation but they tend to
find new work and as automation comes in
it actually often creates new kinds of
jobs for the people that are affected by
it so we haven't really lived through it
you know there's always temporary
displacement and that is a concern it's
not to be overlooked but we haven't
really lived through a time yet where
this has fundamentally transferred sort
of the role of the person to the role of
machines it's just transferred what they
actually do and you used to phrase
before about the Surplus Elite and um
you know it's interesting to think about
those people who are being made
redundant now no doubt their skill set
is going to allow them to find new jobs
I mean these are probably not people who
are going to be out of work for the rest
of your lives but you know you're right
to ask questions about what happens when
one all qualified people don't find
themselves in the workforce but you
could also you know quite simply say
this is simply the effects of the
looming recession the global recession
that you know most people think is
coming I know we've had some good
economic data in the UK maybe if we're
very very lucky we'll we'll miss the
technical definition of recession by a
percentage point but it seems you know
that we are entering into more difficult
Economic Times and it's a reminder that
everyone is affected by that of course
if you're on the lower end of the income
scale you're going to be
disproportionately affected by that but
the Surplus Elites are as well
tough luck on them
um Sam I guess my last question to you
is what do you think this is going to do
from a political perspective now that
the high income earners are experiencing
these layoffs
um that are associated increasingly with
automation are we going to see more of a
backlash might we get some bankers
unions
I don't know it's a it's a nice sort of
ticklish idea um
and I suppose that it's
you know as a rule if you're on the you
know
more affluent end of the scale you know
the the politics that represent you you
know you're probably not really going to
I mean I've
I suppose theoretically there'll be you
know Goldman Sach former Goldman Sachs
employees suddenly joining the corbinite
wing of the labor party but I I can't
see that happening in droves I think
they're pretty much stuck with the
Tories
uh and let's not forget that they
probably have a pretty nice uh payment
packages going out the door and nest
eggs and property so yeah they've got
nowhere else to go I think Sam thanks
for joining me
and finally Noma often referred to as
the world's best restaurant will be
closing its doors what does this mean
for fine dining to discuss I'm joined by
Olivia Potts who writes the spectator's
Vintage Chef column and Rory Sutherland
who writes our Wiki man column
Rory and Liv thanks for joining
spectator TV Liv it's been announced
that Noma often called the world's best
restaurant is closing what do you make
of this
so Noma is known for its experimental
cooking but also it's very intensive
cooking so it serves long tasting menus
uh where you don't swap out dishes and
you pay a substantial amount of money in
advance before you turn up
um and it requires a huge Brigade of
chefs to create this meal for a limited
number of Dimes
and the reason that has really been
given the name of closing is that it
basically doesn't work
it doesn't work as an economic model I
think they've also said that they they
don't feel that they can continue in
good faith doing this in the way that
they perhaps have in the past
um but but basically they can't make
that kind of food for that quantity of
people work financially
um and in the past they have perhaps
they're perhaps done a bit better by
using huge amounts of unpaid labor in
the form of starches which is Chef's
work experience or internships or
long-term paid interns
um and they've stopped doing that in
October and suddenly it's no longer
financially viable
Rory what do you make of all this
I mean it all depends how you define the
world's best restaurant of course
because the world's best restaurant and
before it of course we had El bully
which also closed down I suppose
um the world's best restaurant will
always be almost by definition slightly
weird
and is the best restaurant where you go
once to have the best meal of your life
or what you post rationalize as the best
meal of your life partly because it's
the most expensive meal of your life
um or is the best restaurant one you
like to go back to fairly frequently
and there is a trade-off here between
what you might call Singularity and
repeat business and one thing about fine
dining in general
is that most people don't like it all
the time or very frequently
in fact if you have fine dining meals
three nights in a row or three times in
a week you'll start craving beans on
toast live the found
ER has suggested that the model of fine
dining is just no longer sustainable
also talking about the financial and
emotional toll that it takes on a human
being quote it just doesn't work
um it sounds like the economic model was
questionable for Noma and I'm sure
coming under more and more scrutiny can
you tell us a bit more about the culture
of kitchens as well though because that
seems to be a factor here yeah I think
the kitchen culture is something that
has quite rightly come under increased
scrutiny
um over the last few years
um traditionally kitchens since the
French Revolution have been organized in
brigades
um and there is a lot of sense in that
in the in the way that sort of
individuals are responsible for their
sort of set areas and then come together
as a team to create a meal but what has
gone along with the the Brigade model is
is a an army atmosphere is sort of you
know you go into a kitchen as a as a
junior chef and you are broken down to
be built back up you have to be able to
take shouting you have to be able to
take huge criticism you have to be able
to take often in kitchens violence and
for a long time there was a real
received believe received wisdom that
you know if you couldn't stand that heat
you should get out of the kitchen that
that was the right way for it to be done
and that
um he just really had to toughen up if
he wanted a career in professional
kitchens
that has quite rightly been hugely
criticized in in the past few years
um I think uh red zeppy the the owner of
Noma is one of the chassis come out to
um criticize his own previous behavior
and say I didn't I didn't treat my staff
in the way that I should have done
um and to and and there are other chefs
who said you know I behaved in ways and
ran my kitchen in ways that that I don't
feel good about now so we are starting
to see some kind of accountability
um but there is certainly a truth that
in really high-end kitchens not all of
them buying stretch the imagination but
but a lot
um there is a a pretty unpleasant
working culture that uh fetishizes very
long hours
physical pain
um unpleasant attitudes between staff
and and often in an attempt to kind of
keep up with the pace of that really
intense physical work drug abuse and
alcohol abuse and I think that there's
been a lot of time calling on that
recently and perhaps if we're looking at
healthier working atmospheres it does
make those kitchens that are
particularly intense in the food they're
producing the work they're doing less
sustainable
Rory what do you make of this uh you
know as a diner I sort of look at the
kitchen door and think whatever is
happening behind it is mysterious and
and magical and for a long time assume
that you know scenes from films and
television depicting the kitchen as this
you know extremely aggressive place has
Liv just described just you know that
must be fiction that must be television
and fantasy but
um it sounds like that has been
reflecting what's actually been going on
for staff behind those kitchen doors
yes it raises parallels with figments
like our electronic goods are quite
often manufactured under conditions that
we ourselves wouldn't tolerate you know
there are quite a lot of hearty meat
eaters who would be sickened by a visit
to an abattoir or Sausage Factory and
what happens behind the kitchen door or
indeed the hotel
um staff room door perhaps that might be
even more extreme or the cruise ship
um staff door
um what's actually going on there the
pain conditions
would be considered almost intolerable
but people seem to be willing to turn a
blind eye so long as they're enjoying
the consequences
but I think I think you'll undoubtedly
find that there is a backlash against
this and probably there may be a
backlash against that structure as well
is that fair
uh that the absolutely sort of
militaristic structure of how kitchens
are a a run uh might change I've been
quite intrigued quite a good book
actually very good book uh unreasonable
Hospitality by Will godara has just come
out and he was the chap who ran um uh 11
Madison uh 11 Madison Park in New York
and I think he's gone on now
fascinatingly to run Shake Shack and
it's a very interesting book because it
it points out that their magic was
actually in resolving an apparent
contradiction between what you might
call fine dining which is a kind of
perfectionism and Hospitality which
relies on human warmth and you know the
one of them is absolutely rigorous and
militaristic and the other one by
definition just
requires a much more empathetic approach
and um he argues that their real success
came when they stopped seeing those two
things as opposites and realized you
could resolve them and part of that
involved a different kitchen culture you
know hit his Chef who was absolutely
instrumental in his success uh was told
after he'd thrown food in an employer's
face for doing a bad job that
effectively if that ever happens again
it doesn't matter how eminent you are as
a chef you're out
foreign
do you think that this model then of
restaurants trying to one-up each other
always serving something larger more
extravagant is coming to an end
especially as customers discover what's
been happening Behind These closed doors
presumably more and more of them are not
going to want to support
um that kind of regimen that you and
Rory have been describing
and I really hope that we will see
diners
making informed decisions not to reset
establishments that that we know
um
treat their staff poorly whether that's
front of house or back of house or both
it doesn't really matter
um
I don't think it's I think I mean I
would love it to be the death of
walnutmanship because I I don't think
that's a fun place for restaurants to be
in at the end of the day
eating out in like it's entertainment
isn't it you go to a restaurant not for
its nutritional value but to to be
entertained and to to spend a lunchtime
or an evening there
um I don't believe it will be the end of
interesting maybe weird cooking or even
really high level cooking I hope we'll
see it on a smaller scale and with new
chefs coming through who don't sort of
have have their hand on the throat of
the hospitality industry and that it
will open up I mean I I'm a little bit
of an optimist I'm not I'm not sure how
easy that is but what I am confident of
is that there are
there is real talent out there who
continue to do new and exciting things
with food and we'll continue to do that
in a variety of different ways and
different venues and perhaps what we
will see is that you you won't have to
have gone and done
you're no massage or in the old days in
El bully Stars which every chef ever had
on their CV because they could say
they've been there we'll simply see
people
um being able to kind of step out on
their own little bit more
um and make their Mark without having to
kind of jump jump through these fine
dining Hoops that previously existed I
think there'll always be those
restaurants which in the words of the
michelangana voyage
um partly it's bragging rights partly
that what we spend on a meal rather like
what we spend on wine is not so much a
kind of price value equation we spend
more to mark an occasion
and so there will always be I think a
need for those hyper expensive places
but what you do see is one hyper
competition in a very narrow space
doesn't really need to much improvement
uh it it it becomes a kind of a sensor
kind of um uh you know what's called a
red Ocean strategy and you also notice
phenomena like restaurants deliberately
setting out not to receive missionary
stars because they argue that the cost
of continuing to meet those criteria
both in terms of simple expenditure
but also perhaps in terms of lost custom
you know they would rather run a place
where people you know come back
frequently and where you know you have
maybe you know three sittings at night
and everything is quite a bit more
casual they'd simply rather run that
kind of establishment for all kinds of
other reasons and therefore the
constraints of having a very tightly
defined idea of what fine dining
constitutes
um then becomes a creative obstacle
really so that I mean I think I think
that I think that kind of weird very
high-end restaurant I think there's a
need for it uh fundamentally how
profitable it is to actually do it is
another question you always have that
slightly odd French thing where the
French work almost more for stature than
they do for money it's not completely a
capitalist country and there are always
a lot of French people who would rather
run a loss making restaurant which
frequently has you know Christine
Lagarde as one of the customers they'd
much rather do that than run a chain of
100 highly profitable burger joints so
there are always going to be these weird
um anomalies where people are doing this
for you know status and stature reasons
rather than for commercial reasons Liv
and Rory thanks for joining me
that's it for this week once again
thanks to canacore genuity wealth
management for sponsoring the week in 60
minutes canacord will provide you with
the experience you need to help you
build your wealth with confidence visit
candywealth.com for more information
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
thank you